[Applaudissements]
la motion
vous content de te voir moi aussi je
suis très content je vois quoi ouais
mon chéri alors là bas moi ça va tu veux
tout va bien ça va on est venu pour
faire un peu le bilan de l'année quoi
savoir si tout va mieux qua non est un
ko à wil et avec moi ce que je dis aux
téléspectateurs hier soir nous sommes
des vêtements après une somme d'aller un
peu dansé avec quelques chroniqueurs
voilà la plupart dans ses pas vraiment
danser
et comment fournerie que c'est sa bar
mitsva est tout excité mais c'est
abandonner le mossad merci les noms à
qui fait un comédien elle a vu des
belles pièces montées
avant de vous dévoiler les coulisses de
cette soirée je vais d'abord commencez
donc par tout ce qui se passe pendant
les offres pendant les manifs pendant
les pubs on a réuni quelques unes des
pépites si cyril vous savez que peut
être un terme à l'antenne sachez que
hors antenne c'est un énorme retard bas
on a tombé unis tout compilé pour vous
c'est la gazette d'or
et on commence bien sûr avec cyril qui
choisit toujours bien ses mots quand il
lance un magnéto pascal praud a invité
la doyenne de l'humanité et vous allez
voir elle pète la forme personnes avec
la doyenne de l'humanité soeur penderie
se rendre est né en 1904
léché
mais je l'adoré
très concentré mais maintenant vous
faites dans la vie ou que voulez vous
faire je bouffe dès qu
on voulait revenir également sur cette
magnifique séquence lorsque guillaume
genton n'a pas tari d'éloges envers le
copain d'anissa ils l'adorent pianiste
de saghir mais l'armée est là
c'est également le roi des transitions
petite leçon pour les apprentis
journalistes ils étaient fixés par
rapport aux unes de planètes avis thèmes
connus
j'apprends ça dans le qg de m
[Musique]
les extraterrestres à penser cette
saison si vous êtes invitée sur le
plateau un jour venez toujours bien
coiffée
oui venez toujours bien coiffée car
sinon ça peut nous faire bugger
complètement l'animateur
[Rires]
beaucoup et on fait beaucoup et louf n'a
pas trouvé folle beaucoup du que mes
épaules et enfin y'a rien à dire très
peu mais c'est vraiment une magnifique
famille humaine c'est un mauvais
millésime temps je te dire je sais pas
ce qui est du cas l'année 70 69 70 70
vas-tu nord-ouest une
minute c'est la bouteille que tu ouvres
en premier avec des invités je dirais
que l'événement je dirais qu'il est bien
il non moi tu veux chiisme son physique
devient problématique et
non
comme un renouveau
[Applaudissements]
je savais qu'on allait valable en
m'ouvrant souffler le show des plus
belles séquences airs il est depuis le
30 août dernier date de la première
émission beaucoup de choses ont changé
dans l'émission pour cartonner faut
toujours être dans la proposition
innover et y en a qui a proposé cette
année c'est la personne qui est à côté
de moi il a proposé beaucoup
vestimentairement parlant mais peut-être
peut-être at-il un peu trop de proposer
cette année mais aulas mais classe mais
croûte laisse portuaire cyril cette
année dans les looks c'est un peu
problématique du coup j'ai appelé un
expert lavigne a passé au crible au
crible un peu tout le monde tenus
regardez là d'un ami
[Musique]
je mets des affaires je ne sais pas ce
qui me tombe sous la main à quoi on
n'est pas dans le dos tiens ça ne vient
pas
beaulieu pardonnez lui non mais c'est
hyper drôle parce que il affiche entre
hop tu sais comme en 2005 c'est très
sympa mort par deux chèques le gillette
pêche n'est pas possible mais je vous
regarde puis tallard et je me dis qu'il
ya vraiment quelque chose l'a fait why
lapointe s'est passé mais je suis je
délire moi on dirait qu'il a été très
d'ailleurs depuis que pendant deux jours
devant d'une forêt quelle horreur
chaussures c'est cher en plus et c'est
les jo lance un nouveau look paul roux
et sur le col roulé le choc et les
baskets c'est très joli séparément mais
sur la même tenue franchement c'est la
loose parue elle est très beaux mollets
il est 19 heures 26 on est en direct et
ses douches marbre
oui effectivement un petit côté dany
brillant c'est plutôt un côté dany comme
aucun cela
des retouches pas bon
merci d'être là arias et dyala c'est
chic là c'est vraiment professionnel on
dirait même carole rousseau en revue
tous les maux des cheveux je sens que la
boucle est un peu séché il ya un petit
souci à petit j'ai pas sa boucle pas
bien lourd et de la laine de new delhi
crois pas vraiment et petits camarades
tu es vraiment manie merci vraiment mais
si vous êtes super de s'installer dans
la patrie de cuir très vite pour monter
parce que la dernière fois et lors d'une
soirée olé olé ils étaient tous habillés
comme ça je peux dire que la fin de la
soirée ça sentait pas la violette
quand j'ai compris le pauvre il s'est
fait attaquer par l'american staff de
pernikoff aulas la loose et chérie on va
passer à un autre sujet j'aimerais qu'on
parle de médailles alors qu'il était
chez le coiffeur c'est très joli mais on
est les deux il est chez nous
ok tribunal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai je les adore je l'avais juste
je viens de recevoir un sms de géraldine
maillet à à 19h23 syrie il ya bertron et
hugo qui sont dans le public tu les as
vus
[Rires]
vous inquiétez pas parce que je voulais
que ce soit pour la dernière ont fait
pas bien sûr ils ont fait la litanie de
tmp faut qu'ils soient contents on n'est
pas là mais vous inquiétez pas vous
allez venir ces bombes qui ont envie de
partir oui c'est l'heure du bilan et
donc on va revenir sur les plus gros
font rire que vous avez eu à l'antenne
et les plus grands fous rires que vous
avez eue hors antenne ce pourquoi je
suis payé on commence par ce qui s'est
passé à l'antenne avec le numéro 3 j'ai
plus de pleurer de rire sur cette
séquence c'était incroyable si je vous
dis disco show
avec matthieu delormeau à la le garder
j'avais oublié le discours que je suis
est incroyable c'est un programme sa
dette
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ja
de disco show
[Applaudissements]
voilà
qui te disent qu il
faut le refaire le matin prime mais
datant pas faire ça qu'on ne prenons
plus quand même mais l'année prochaine
dans la saison n'est pas finie a préféré
brochures ont ciblé la saison wayne est
partout ok je vous rappelle que vous ne
reveniez 19h36 à 20 heures ah oui vous
dire exactement ce qui va se passer
awilo réhaussée par année pour tpm paix
pour vous mais pour l'humanité oui vu
tirer leur deuxième position c'était
lordat jus du cul savez ces mesures il
est chroniqueur devrait passer tel
physique ces défis savait que bahia une
chroniqueuse qui a répondu un peu trop
mais souffre le magnéto cyril
we have ou trois choses que tu cries
pendant le sexe c'est très bon état
[Applaudissements]
le nombre à ce projet
ça venait du coeur en fête
[Rires]
va j'aime bien les petits jeux comme ça
où il faut et c'est vrai que quand on
fait ces jeux forcément quand le monde
aurait dit un truc un peu osée enfin un
truc un peu olé olé olé olé la voilà aia
qui êtes bon dans ces jeux excellents
au pyla monsieur répartissent à la
première position donc des fous rires
qui a eu à l'antenne dans un instant on
va voir ce qu'il ya eu entente n est en
première position il ya deux
chroniqueurs qui se sont accouplés cette
saison incluant donner un enfant
magnifique qui voulaient se rappeler de
cette séquence d'anthologie
syrie attention enfants vieux à venir
il s'agit d'
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est extraordinaire
ben barka chef
cas on passe maintenant courir hors
antenne ce que vous n'avez pas vu à la
télé que c'était pendant les pubs
c'était pendant les magnétos et alors on
commence avec le numéro 3 ce fameux jour
où vous receviez un ami cyril un ami
très talentueux philippe lellouche alors
davantage avec cyril c'est que quand on
est vraiment proche de lui il ne se font
jamais de votre gueule ou pas si c'est
un trio va regarder si paul biya t'offre
propose une info vous me dîtes si elle
concerne maths ou philippe la première
fois qu'on m'a vu à la télé j'avais une
coupe de cheveux autres mike brant et
mireille mathieu
ce que je peux dire aujourd'hui que le
karaoké devenu un véritable phénomène de
société il ya cinq ans pour appliquer à
débarquer en force
les gens pensent
m
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
m
[Applaudissements]
blu ray
on est comme je reste élégante et
essayent tout est a souffert ils
entraîneront mais c'est quoi cet
hématome asseoir aussi
mais ça va ça passe en deuxième position
et ça aurait pu vraiment étant numéro un
c'est le crush de daniel moreau nous a
fait vivre un vrai moment d'émotion j'ai
nommé jean le poulain
et sekita pour ton premier mais qui
s'appelait comment ah non j'ai pas
draguer tout de suite
et au fonctionnement fumeux bravo at
hemmuc pourquoi basques à la maison
toujours
[Rires]
nous avons interdit 4
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
roulers et le président de l'association
des mauvaises foi de france quand ils la
font rire est il obligé absolument
remettre la voiture qu'elle tu as
regardé
son émotion de trail tu vois bien que
rim est de tuer un chien je parle d'un
chien que je vais acheter malin moi
aussi je sais d'où il vient après
aujourd'hui les american staff en train
de les mélanger les uns avec les autres
c'est facile il a eu peur il a sauté un
truc mais tu ne peux pas vrai à la
mairie pour le fait que c'est un chien
qui ne risquait rien me collard ça vous
fait marrer lakic identique et ça te
fais ma recette c'est marion ça fait mal
[Applaudissements]
l'album qui va nous rejoindre dans un
instant la wii qui est elle si new delhi
avant avant de repartir il alors dans un
instant vous allez je vous ai réunis les
on l'a vu alors pour ceux qui ne se
souvient pas de ce que c'est c'est les
chroniqueurs qui font des petits ménages
on les voit dans des clips avec données
dans des films dans des émissions télé
c'est incroyable et avance à cyril je
voudrais vous remercier vous parce que
je sais que vous détestez ça mais il ya
très peu d'animateurs qui laissent leur
chance à des jeunes comme moi pas très
talentueux donc merci bas pour tout ce
que vous faites merci aussi à tous ceux
qui bossent sur l'indiquent cas combes
et marque fabien adèle les auteurs etc
les graphismes ont été lancés
il ya tout sûr c'est pourquoi il ya tout
ce monde là
encore tous ces gens là pour ça
car on va juste un petit bisou avant eux
pour pour tous pour toute l'aide sur
lundi que cette saison va la vendre à
partir cyril c'est le on l'a vu lors on
l'a vu c'est les chroniqueurs qui sont
dans des films art et ses stands et
ensuite c'est magnifique vous adorez ça
à la maison et ben je vous en a ramené
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau un génie
[Musique]
et des nouveautés les anciens
[Applaudissements]
on commence avec raymond qui en ce
moment est de plus en plus fan de george
michael effet d'après moi parce que ça
commence à se voir
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
m
[Musique]
non mais vous rendez compte de ce que
vous dites attendait l'american staff
j'ai joué dans camping paradis mois
[Musique]
alors
on attend pas patrick et quand on voit
la séquence qui va suivre on comprend
mieux pourquoi bernard montiel n'a joué
que dans sous le soleil vous voulez vous
allez dans une vraie fée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec benjamin castaldi
chaque forte que capuches et des
capuches et jaurès page d'histoire
[Musique]
on le pensait numéro uniquement à
mykonos mais c'est aussi un patron de la
chanson française j'ai nommé mathieu
delormeau
les gardes
et fabrice di vizio avant de venir sans
pato va ça y est c'est bon il est
vacciné tout va bien pour lui enfin
presque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après sous les bombes découvrez la
version sous le zen avec gilles verdez
du trot
[Musique]
à
leur servent à leur sens
avant de repartir mon fils et grossir
ils comptent partir en vacances pâtes et
de plus voir la gueule des chroniqueurs
[Applaudissements]
merci de savoir comment elle allait
m